[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm Linc
man I'm glad you're listening because
this week at the round table of dim
lighting we're talking at each other and
going down a rabbit hole where's it
gonna take us we don't know we've got an
envelope depends on what the rabbit
decided when he dug it with a topic of
discussion maybe a question I don't know
have it seen it well that's that that is
an interesting question is the rabbit
hole that we're going to go down
determined already by a rabbit that dug
it or are we the rabbits digging the
hole that's a deep philosophical
question it's a mythical beast who
responded to a social media post that's
not what I'm talking about
I'm not talk about who asked the
question yeah I'm saying the people
going down the rabbit hole
are we the rabbits digging the hole in
determining would the direction of the
hole are we following a hole that has
already been determined ahead of time
it's really a question about determinism
oh well the same catch-up link the
saying it implies that there's a hole
and you're just going down it it you're
not the rabbit so you believe that our
conversation is already determined we
are you saying that we do not have free
will and how we interact with the
question that we're going to free will
free will if it is on the hole Oh link
annoys makes fun of the way I say white
white every time I say white he says
white
yeah after me look because there's an H
in it white white well are we gonna
prematurely go down another rabbit hole
which is just organism versus free will
I thought operation I just raised the
question I mean I when I you know the
story of my concussion is what really
made me pause and start to think about
the determinism of conversations in a
life in general is a really good point
you know as we talked about in our tour
of mythicality we have a whole bit about
it we also have a book which is a which
comes from this story in the book about
me breaking my pelvis and losing eight
hours of memory because well you don't
lose eight hours of memory because of
your pelvis I also hit my head well link
keeps his memory in his
it's a it's deeper it's an unusual keep
my memory D it's actually more protected
down there but my point is you put me in
a certain situation and the the
concussion allowed me to be in the
situation again and again and again and
I kept saying the exact same thing again
and again and again right so if you say
a certain thing with certain I mean
there's lots of variables but with all
of those variables cascading from the
Big Bang mm-hmm
- now I'm bound I mean I I could I could
I could easily believe if you twisted my
arm hard enough that man with all the
variables I'm bound to respond in a
certain way well and most research shows
that you actually you're your frontal
cortex is just narrating the decision
that another part of your brain already
made and so it's making you think that
you made a decision but really the
decisions that you make are just your
DNA interacting with the environment
that doesn't make life any less meaning
meaningful it just means that you really
fought saying meaningless twice
it doesn't make life less meaningful it
just means that the me and you are just
what it makes my wire in a certain way
and we're going to look at this question
in the way that we're gonna interact
with this question is already determined
man I think you're making this podcast
feel more meaningless because the
moments that if I were gonna listen this
podcast the moments that I would be
listening for and perking up for will be
the points where it's like where the
unexpected thing happens I mean but but
to you and to me and to the Creator
laughter it creates thought yeah but
none of that change free eights people
get really upset when people start
making that argument but but it doesn't
change your experience me and you're
gonna interact with this question as if
in art and we're gonna be narrating to
ourselves that we are making all these
decisions and coming all this stuff and
the person listening is gonna be
reacting to it because they're hearing
it for the first time but even their
reaction to it is predetermined I mean
it's not rigged ed upset about it
but I'm gonna say it doesn't change life
at all if you go to a car dealership and
you're like oh I'm excited I'm gonna buy
a car I'm so excited about this and I'm
gonna I get let's say I've won the
lottery and I get the pick of the litter
any car that I want off the lot but then
and help me with this analogy that's
always a good sign but then you but then
somebody as you walk in the front doors
with the power and the ability to pick
any car you want and just drive off the
lot like a mogul leans over and whispers
in your ear and says we already know
which car you're gonna buy and all the
paperwork's done the plates are on it
and it's it's it's already taken care of
I can't think that that wouldn't
negatively impact my experience I was
like man you just ruined it for me I won
the lottery I'm gonna roll out of here
like a mogul I the process of like
picking out the car but now in my mind
I'm like which one did I already pick
for that now I need to pick again
but hold on and I would feel no not like
my experience was robbed but here's
where they tell me that analogy breaks
down because by saying that things are
determined ahead of time and that
ultimately your decisions consist of
your genetic makeup interacting with an
environment is not the environment is
also that car dealer coming up to you
the the salesmen and saying you've
already made a decision we know which
one you're gonna pick at that point the
environment has now changed and so your
DNA is your mind is gonna react to that
and you may end up picking something
different than you would if he had not
interacted with you in that way but it
would have been the thing that he
whispered in my and and said that he
knew so I wouldn't have changed that it
would have changed it he would then have
been lying but you don't know it's
impossible or it's very difficult to
calculate the probability of how much
his interaction with you and telling you
that he already knows what you're gonna
do would impact your decision but that
doesn't mean that you actually had the
choice to make a different decision it
just means that the environment impacted
your decision
but it still feels like a choice so
what's the difference I think I'm just
gonna turn around go back to my farty
old car and just get in it and drive
away and say you know what I'm no-one's
pawn right and nobody would win at that
point I've lost
they've lost business they shouldn't
have whispered it in my ear that was
their pride that was their mistake if
you know what someone's gonna do you
don't whisper it in their ear that but
the thing what you're gonna do is that
an omniscient computer who analyzed your
environment and your your genetic makeup
put you put you into that situation they
could determine ahead of time if they
had perfect ability to interpret all the
events they would be able to interpret
they would all be able to perfectly
predict that in the end you would say
screw it I'm going back home nobody's my
boss that doesn't mean that you didn't
have agency it just means that it was it
was you didn't really have it means that
agency is not exactly I don't even like
to talk about this because all it does
is make people mad people get so upset
when you start telling them that you're
actually not making any free decisions
you're you're just interacting with your
environment
I felt it actually makes me feel better
that does one of the good things about
it
uh Ron eclis it's like you know it's
like once it's done it's like I did it
and I couldn't have done anything else
once it's done it's like I did it okay
well let me uh let me airport my phone
here it's buzzing well who is that is
that business or pleasure
it would both yourself it was just a
slack conversation the office slack
conversation which could get a little
overwhelming the general slack
especially you know it's just general
slack comes in here with his tanks
before we get into the question though I
do want to I was talking to you a little
bit about this I had an interesting
experience last night I was in the
father-son 3-point contest
my son's basketball league and and so
this is like what why does this exist
fun man fun times oh it's just for fun
well it's not a it's a fun fundraiser
okay to raise to raise money for the
team so who was did you give money or
did you just show up and grace them with
your three point presents both how much
money did you donate I'm not gonna tell
you that six million dollars I've
floated I'm floating the team for the
next seven generations
so anyway Locke tells me on Monday well
first of all on Monday we're going to
this thing he's like dad there's a
there's a fundraiser and I was Saturday
night I'm going to shoot free throws I'm
gonna shoot a hundred free throws and
you have to like give a certain amount
of money for every one I make or
whatever he was like also there's a dad
three-point contest he tells me that
says I'm driving in there my clock I
don't what oh as you're driving to the
thing yeah we told me this on Saturday
but when we got there it's really I was
upset with him because he thought that
it was Saturday night and I was like you
got to tell me you know I care about
these things you know I'm competitive
you know what this is a dad vs. dad
situation that I want to be you know I
want my game to be in tune oh you got it
you got a prime the pump on your but it
turns out shot it wasn't Saturday it was
last night so he asked several nicely he
accidentally gave you a heads up right
so but you still got angry with him and
that's all that that's that's a good
part but I still didn't practice what I
yeah you were going to practice tending
to practice right because in television
and then the situation entertain holes
around last night and I'm sitting up
there and I'm like looking at the other
dads and I mean I'm like first of all
LOX kind of shoot there's no you know
there's not a lot of room for area here
because he shoots five three-pointers
and then I shoot five we go around the
horn all around the world from one elbow
to the other elbow and so you get ten
and it's it's hard to just and that's it
get out of the stands and not get into a
groove and just start hitting
three-pointers now had he shot a hundred
free-throws already on Saturday night
yeah okay tonight yeah so I see a guy
there's no warmup huh for the three
points all it was
is once it got to be that set that part
of the night because there was like a
kids three-point contest and there was
like a mom and son free-throw contest
now I'm there for that yep and a kid
3-point contest that also sounds ah no
hazing it was absolutely riveting the
whole night and then it gets down to the
moment we've all been waiting for the
dad three-point contest and I can look
around and I see that there's other dads
who are pretty serious including one guy
who was in a head to toe North Carolina
Tarheels basketball uniform what yes and
as you know even though people assume
that we are fans of North Carolina
because we're from North Carolina we
quite the I hate them we hate them with
a fiery passion if the school could
completely just be obliterated without
any of the actual individuals being
harmed and I can press a button I would
do it you press the button I press a
button if it meant that all of the
people could be safe but all the
buildings in the institution and the in
the Dean Smith Center could just
completely blow up I would do it I'm
just gonna be honest we can I hold your
hand while you did it and can I make it
push harder I mean and you know I don't
hate Duke that's the thing I don't also
hate Duke I don't like Duke because it's
still a rival but I with a fiery passion
hate UNC and I would just like to back
away slowly from your fervor because you
know in college and my wife went there
by the way it was really fun to have an
archrival especially when they refused
to acknowledge that we even exist right
because it made it even worse they don't
consider us a rival because we suck so
bad at sports historically Duke but
their rival you past 30 years or so and
so in college I cared about it but now I
mean the Wolfpack have burnt me so much
that I'm I I'm still you know I still
claim my alma mater don't get me wrong
but like I don't watch the games like
you do I don't feel all of it and I
don't I don't get upset at him I still
embrace my life has extended well being
an NC State fan has given me a level of
character that other people people who
are UNC fans don't have
you know when your team actually wins
national championships and they hold on
cheating included by the way I will
throw that out there do the Tar Heels
not have character to clarify your
statement because they don't lose or
because they're horrible people once you
submit yourself to that school for four
years or so
you lose character right I saw it
happening to my wife I saw it happen to
my brother you know they win in certain
people and they came out people without
character right and it's slowly
throughout the years I've slowly built
her character back oh you have yeah yeah
well cuz I went to NC State you see your
credit I'm sure she thanks you all the
time for building her character back so
anyway I see this guy in the head to toe
he had on frickin UNC sucks I do hate
him you know and I was like what the
crap what is wrong with you man of
course I went and talked to him and I
had to talk to I was like oh you NC huh
did you go school they're always doubt
that they go to school there cuz it's
kind of like the Lakers you know yeah
like you where it doesn't mean you're a
fan it I hope he went there if he's got
a full outfit he better team in his he
was not on the team in his defense he
did graduate from UNC I think I was like
well I went to NC State he was like oh a
CC battle now what are you wearing I'm
actually wearing exactly what I have on
right now this shirt these jeans
different underwear in what kind of I
want not as shoes I wore like my
high-top gray great high tops okay so
I'm you're Air Force One I'm ready but
no the other ones that zip up now but
you see you just you just walked in off
the street every other dad is also not
in a full basketball uniform one one guy
was in Aggie one dad was in Aggie
hold on yes I don't know if he's excited
about the new Cobra Kai on YouTube bread
or what but you didn't talk he didn't
talk to him dick no I refuse this what
you do man and Aggie you should cease
actively fighting unless he gene you
also shouldn't talked to the Chapel Hill
guy no full regalia
I had to so what do you didn't have to I
wanted to intimidate him oh so I talked
to him and did he apologize for
he's self-conscious about his yeah he
said III live only only worn this I've
only worn this one time and that was
when we won the championship two years
ago yeah thanks for other than that jerk
but she's I don't get a chance to wear
this and I almost thought well this is
not the chance I mean you know but good
you know he he is playing basketball
anyway but by the way super nice guy he
seems to cut most of his character he's
not playing basketball by the way he's
shooting five three-pointers he's
actually shooting ten cuz he's got two
sons so he gets to do it twice oh good
for him sorry that level of character
hey anyway I had two children I'm gonna
have to throw Locke under the bus here
sorry Locke but uh Lawton missed all
five of his three-pointers and he's a
great three-point shooter I was it was
just a little bit of an off night for
him did you yell at him no but I gave
him a very piercing look of
disappointment which I've gotten very
good at and so then I'm like okay this
is all on me and of course I'm not
actually thinking I you know I'm a
little bit of a narcissist and very
selfish so I'm not thinking about the
McGlothlin you wanna you want to blog
anything right now after you've made the
narcissist no I didn't talk about this
on Twitter or or Instagram which would
be read em see both places shout out but
no I didn't do that
anyway so once Locke has missed all five
I'm just like this is about me oh you
know I'm saying this is about me saving
face this is about but before then it
wasn't all about you right when
McLaughlin team McLaughlin had a chance
it was about team McLaughlin but now
it's just about team ret you know what
I'm saying and so first of all a lot of
these kids know who I am and so there's
that pressure it's like okay here's the
Internet comedian getting up there and
and he's tall he we know he likes to win
things so at this point I'm like well I
can't look like a jerk I wish I was
there so I could have kept score like an
old days pretty easy to keep score when
somebody shooting five three-pointers so
I get up there a little disappointed and
block having missed all of them and I
line up the first one air ball
just short they missed everything and
again but historically I'm a good
shooter so immediately there's a there's
a wave of embarrassment that begins to
come over
yeah but I'm like this is these are the
kind of moments I live for starting off
a five the five string three point
series with an airball step up to the
next one what did anyone chant airball
well lots of dad's had air-balled one
guy threw it over the entire goal one
time I mean dads aren't made for
shooting the backboard yeah that dad's
most ads and they're not ready for this
yeah yeah I would have I would have not
been not embarrassed second
three-pointer
swish I'm back on track third
three-pointer from the top of the key
another air ball now that that's the
place where you could easily Bank it in
which again it's not not cool but it
would have counted yeah one dad did that
and several mom's did that on free
throws so now I'm one for three 33% not
real bad when it comes to three-pointers
but two of them are air balls which is
real bad
mm and then the fourth one swish swish I
only swish I never I don't hit the rim I
either get either goes in or air balls
you're not gonna hit that ramp and then
my last one fifth one swish swish so I
made three out of five 60% pretty good I
wish I had an air ball but at that point
I was just like the guy in the full
Carolina outfit cannot make more than
three out of five or else I will feel
defeated that was your game at that
point that was all I cared about just
tying him because I knew he's gonna have
to chance him tying you all right and
long story short the first time around
he hit three and he missed the fifth one
he had made three out of four and
Jesse's recording this on her phone on
her phone and to rub it in your face on
the fifth one will have to poster her
instagram story I'm not gonna show her
around I don't want you guys to flutter
the fit the fifth one he would have been
a four out of five he missed it and I
every there was an audible yes on her
Instagram short it was me just
involuntarily just screaming yes it
wasn't like super loud I was I was right
next to her phone I couldn't help it man
he's freaking we're in the enemy's
uniform and then he gets it there for a
second
he didn't start heck line in he makes
three again so and no dad made more than
three there were there was like four of
us that made three so I left with a
little bit of my pride intact to
airballs though got to work on that rat
a little bit of disappointment in my son
a little bit of disappointment in myself
you know just an average Wednesday we're
gonna go down a rabbit hole after we
crack open an envelope here in a second
but first we just got a share a little
merch action with you of course I'm
wearing a GMM gray on black tea and my
friend hanger here is wearing the I want
my GMM shirt you know it's kind of in
the style of your classic late 90s or
late 80s early 90s just in time for
summer summer shirt yeah you need that
we're at the pool wear it at the beach
wear it in your home when no one's in
the reach mythical dot store that's the
place to get all that and more thanks
for supporting internat Ament all right
let's uh let's take the top envelope
here I'm opening it up having never seen
it you said that as if you're lying you
know having never seen it yeah like a
magician I've never met this man before
I just trained him earlier tonight we
haven't actually seen it
Morgan Post did why do people
procrastinate why is putting something
off only to have to deal with it all in
one go and in such a short amount of
time much more tempting okay Morgan you
want us to get into the the art or the
vice of procrastination you must know
why people do it he can't understand it
so we should we should each probably say
you know where we fall in this spectrum
because it's not it's not a I do or I
don I imagine it's it's more of just a
general trajectory of procrastination or
not would you consider yourself a
procrastinator
this is a tough question for you it's
easy for me so I would not consider you
a procrastinator by any means no I mean
I what I think about procrastination I
always think of it in terms of like test
hike high school in college or haiku
haiku which I almost said yeah he almost
got a scholarship to haiku so whenever I
get a haiku assignment or I'm being
tested on my haikus I'm I'm like
immediately studying how would you test
haikus I think it's is it the right
number of syllables or not you count the
syllables if it isn't you blow it it's
an F you blew it
how many syllables is it could you tell
me that I should because I just watched
that movie because we talked about it
Taika Waititi movie what's it called
searching for the wilderness for the
wilder people is how I would say louder
people sure excellent movie watched it
watched it with the kids they did I was
like all right kids like you it's it's
Friday night let's have a family movie
night and I'm like yes I have the
perfect movie I'm actually keeping a
list of movies so we no longer have to
argue for 30 or 45 minutes on what
movies everybody worst
so basically I've started keeping a list
of movies that I want to see that they
can tolerate and then I'm just making an
executive decision that's good be a dad
but yeah because otherwise we never get
anywhere and and I know how to make
everybody happy with this movie well and
so I said we're gonna watch it
everybody's groaning and I'm like no
groaning you don't know anything about
the movie I think they know everything
you tell him something that's just and
then they get grown as it like like they
had decided like it was predetermined
that they were gonna grown it didn't
matter what I was gonna say do the same
thing with food yeah it's like um even
if it's something they love like we're
gonna get some Mexican food takeout no
it's it's like there has to be their
idea I don't get it
teens man well I got some in our teens
doing it me too it's just progeny yeah
children it's our fault in the movie
which I highly recommend for family
viewing all viewing the kid says haikus
you remember that yeah it's been a while
since you've watched it so I think it's
it's it it's five syllables is it five
seven five anyway
really great movie I just freaking love
the first 30 minutes it's so funny it's
funny throughout but like really funny
I'll call it an indie ish movie five
seven five is a haiku what was I saying
oh that sometimes even the funniest
movies by the second half they're not
funny anymore this one's even better and
this I wouldn't say got better but it
didn't get unfunny and that's a hard
thing to do with it with a movie and
this that Krylov new zealand sense of
humor is just so delectable it's my face
I think it's my favorite so dry it's so
it's my favorite and that's why I like
Thor Ragnarok because taiga also
directed that yeah I love that guy and
and what we do in the show the rock guy
will be wrong with you in the shadows
what we're doing the shadows humm for
the water people if you have not done
yourself the favor of watching both of
those movies what are you doing I think
you can't doing with your life I would
say you can't be sleepy because you have
to be in tune to it like what we do in
the shadows I actually saw it twice I
think and I was very sleepy both times
it's like you have to have a level of
concentration in order to really
appreciate it because that's not
actually what was dry companies that was
one of those movies that experimented
with the sleep the sleep induction you
didn't know that I didn't know I didn't
yeah yeah well you should have known
that you would have been capped up it
didn't make me sleepy I was just already
sleepy so for me I hate procrastination
because I just hate having an assignment
looming and then not not making progress
on it like I don't have to complete
something but I have to know
that I have to do enough to know that I
can complete it easily like cuz
something about about the way my brain
works I think with everything that
becomes a to-do item especially with
tests back in the day on my haikus I
think the way I interact with those
psychologically was I always started
from a place even though it was a very
diligent student that I was going to
fail
hey I just wish that I would have gone
to therapy much earlier in life honestly
to start to unpack these type of things
like I never stopped and thought to
myself okay the moment you get an
assignment for a test you have this
sinking feeling that is a dread that
like like oh yeah this means automatic
failure for me or on the opposite side
of it I said sometimes I think I would
think I think I would think that my
standard was perfection and then it was
a sinking feeling unless I knew I could
achieve perfection I think that rings
true for me both of those factors
together a would be great to have talked
through with a with a qualified
therapist I think that's a that's
something I would have I wish I would
have done in college so that being said
the way that I would cope is I would
start to study immediately or I think
actually a long time ago in ear biscuits
I talked about another example which was
just engineering school as an example
and my heart was never in it yet my time
and my energy my blood sweat and tears
was all invested in it just because I
was doing it I had to do it as perfectly
as possible so to me that's very tied to
procrastination because yeah then it's
like I have no defense it's my fault if
I wait too late and it's like okay well
I didn't know how much time it was gonna
take for me to know that I get aced this
test and I will never have more time
than I have right now to know how much
time I need well I think is so I I mean
so just because you're not a pro crass
it doesn't mean that you're healthy I
think I've just proven that I mean in
college I was definitely a
procrastinator
if procrastination is waiting like
postponing getting into something I
don't do that as much anymore mm-hmm but
the same factors that contributed to
procrastination which I think this gets
a little bit at Morgan's question like
why do people procrastinate its how
easily distracted I am right the main
factor is how easily distracted I am so
I get that whereas you have like a laser
focus on things it's kind of like a it's
like it's kind of like a laser focused
like a tube like the way that I picture
your your attention see this is like a I
don't see that at all you see what I'm
doing
no cuz I have social left there's a tube
that's going right to your your face I'm
making a flying butterfly with my hands
underneath the butterfly but like for
instance you know it's good it didn't
distract you I noticed this when we ride
together we haven't been carpooling
together that much because we're going
into different gyms and stuff cuz our
relationships on the rocks but or even
the other day when we were getting ready
in the in the in the in the ready room
the ready room the wardrobe room
my mom has a ready room it's an entire
room dedicated to her getting ready in
the morning so what we do typically with
we're getting ready to shoot some some
good mythical morning is the writer and
producer of that particular episode kind
of come in and begin talking through
what we're about to shoot just even
though we have familiarized ourselves
what we're gonna do is just like we're
getting everybody's getting all their
ducks in a row especially for the more
complex episodes and then there was
music playing in the room now the music
playing in the room was so quiet that I
had forgotten that music was playing in
the room but Bobbie Gentry but I play I
started playing that music before we got
there but so the they come in the room
and they start talking to us and I
noticed like 15 seconds in them talking
you get up you go over there and you
turn the music all the way off and I'm
like oh you
it was playing and that music playing
which I didn't hear was a distracting
link so he couldn't listen to the or and
when we ride together which is what I
was getting to well first first okay go
ahead I'll come back to the music but go
ahead this is also a music example I've
noticed that when we are riding in a car
if we're talking you don't want music to
be playing at all it's not like I
remember been Greenwoods mom used to
play music almost were you like on is
the radio on now uh-huh I was like what
is the point of that right now right
whereas in my family is more like we
play music where most people would be
like why are you playing it that loud
and trying to have a conversation at the
same time but that's it in my house all
the time like Saturday morning that
music starts playing oh yeah yeah well
also most weekday mornings like music
starts playing and we're having
conversations we play music while we
dinner at night and like sometimes it's
like loud but it we but everybody's on
the same page is how we interact with
each other so there's music that you're
enjoying what you're also in the midst
of a conversation but like if we
intervene on the road and the music has
been Greenwoods mom level you have to
turn it off
before we begin a conversation now I'm
not good bad or indifferent but what
that does is it highlights the amount of
Tolerance that you have for anything
that might be distracting now my
tolerance is so high for things that
might be distracting that I get drawn
into them so when I sit down that
doesn't make sense no no what I'm saying
is is that I thought you were gonna if
you're gonna say that you never get
distracted by things then you would
never be drawn off of your task to them
no my propensity to incorporate those
things into my life and in a way that is
like it doesn't compromise my
conversation with my wife or with my
kids or even a conversation that would
be having with you especially music
because it's the kind of thing that you
can easily categorize and be like oh
there's music playing but now I'm having
this conversation with Linc about this
serious thing and and I don't I'm not
hearing the music anymore what I'm
saying is my tendency to leave things on
and kind of leave like leave a lot of
tabs on my computer open leave a lot of
apps open what that ends up doing is
I've just set the table against myself
with a high number of things that could
at any point draw me in so it's actually
gotten worse as we've gotten older back
in the day in college it would be like I
put things off I do the classic work
right just let me jump in on about the
music and save it a lot of these things
that you know I'm not gonna take it as a
criticism I'm not gonna take it is you
think that I'm lesser because I'm just
tracking about things I'm gonna leave
that I'm not gonna take it personal it
sounds like that's how you're taking it
anyway it's hard not to take it that way
but I'm not okay but I just want to go
and say the reason why I turn off the
music is for you because you're the one
who might get pulled into that now I
hate to do that to you I appreciate that
that's not true by the way
my turn the music off because yes
distracting it's distracting to me
because I know what I'm into I I started
playing the music I know what it is so I
have a connection to it it's not
background music there like else I
walked in the room and it was just there
no it's something I was listening to
intently and then I'm like yeah I don't
want to pull myself away from it but
that's my point my point is is that if
the question was why do people have
Krassin aid and I think that it is a
direct correlation between the your
tolerance to so in other words if you
have a laser focus on things then you're
much less likely to get pulled into
other things that would distract you and
keep you from getting into the thing
that you want and it may be your anxiety
that drew you in it in the first place
to doing it but I'm saying that once you
get into something what I'm gonna do is
like I do the the most work that I do at
this point that's anything related like
a test is like sitting down and writing
something mm-hmm and I'll sit down and
write something but if you were to look
at a like a graph of my time when I say
I'm gonna set aside this day to write
something mm-hmm it'll be like right for
20 minutes read an article right for 31
minutes go check my email and I'm not
saying this is healthy I'm just saying
that that's how I approach it now so now
it's just a bunch of distractions that
get thrown into what I'm doing which
prolongs the time that it takes but it's
not procrastination but in yeah but in
some weird way my tendency to interact
with those things ends up impacting
especially creative for it kind of
coming back in because once I if I just
go nose down into something and it's
like for like three hours in I'll be
like I can't do this anymore I need a
distraction to like almost fill the tank
up again but procrastination is
different so let's talk about I think in
this instance it would be that you're
intentionally doing something that is
not pressing instead of doing the doing
the task that is more pressing the say
the thing that you set out to write so
and in that moment I am procrastinating
if I'm not even if I've started but
taking a taking a brain break or like
stepping away so you can step back in is
probably an efficiency to a certain
point but it's all about motives like
are you not doing it because you don't
think you've got anything or are you
looking elsewhere for inspiration that
you need are you avoiding a task it's
much more carnal than that it's more
there's something else what is that it's
not like man I'm getting tired of this I
need to actively make a decision to open
a tab again that's not how my brain
works my brain is like oh I'm now been
reading this article for seven minutes I
don't remember making a decision to do
that do you know I'm saying it's like so
do you think subconsciously that is
procrastination yeah because it's put in
in that moment it is because this
pudding site is putting a task off but
and I think to read between the lines
and to know you I think it would you say
it's because the other thing is is more
exciting it's it's more in that moment
intriguing yeah and I thought about like
doing the thing where you get the
you put the app on your phone or your
computer where you can't get on the
internet for a certain amount of time
but I'm like what if I need a lot of
times I'm in the middle of writing
something I'm like got a Google saw I
need the Internet and then I'll remember
something that I want to buy like I mean
it really is kind of sad I'm yeah I
don't know why you took what I said
personally because it wasn't personal it
was Altima a compliment and in the
context of across the nation because if
you looked at what I did in a day that I
was trying to be productive I would have
like bought three or four things that I
don't need I would have read articles I
would have clicked on an article that
was like what do these celebrities look
like now like I like that stuff is
designed for people with my personality
yeah and after I've clicked on an
article and then clicked on an article
and then clicked on an article it isn't
like I'm sitting around thinking I'm
awesome because I click on all these
articles I'm thinking why can't I just
do the thing that I was trying what I
was trying to do so I think it's a
little bit and I've never been diagnosed
with ADHD but I think that people who
again we're not doctors or scientists
that we don't really know what we're
talking about but I have to assume that
people who have an attention deficit
disorder are much more likely to to
procrastinate because even if it's not
just something that's keeping you from
even beginning a task which used to be
my problem but now my life is a lot more
scheduled and so I'll be like I need to
do this I'm going to start doing it now
but then my road to getting it finished
will have all kinds of potholes in it
some productive most of it not
productive so for me why I procrastinate
is because of my attention deficit
issues in Morgan you're gonna shame him
for that did we answer the complete
question well I was putting something on
it I mean because I think you know when
he says why is putting something off
only to have to deal with it all in one
go and in such a short amount of time
much more tempting it's the other things
that are tempting he's a he's applying a
like a
early logical analysis of
procrastination it's like and that's
just not how it works either way I mean
plenty of people procrastinate from fear
of not being able to get it done so
you'd rather do something else to make
yourself feel better and something's
gonna make you feel worse like like
failing in the process of doing it I'm
just guessing do you want to open
another question I think we settled that
one I think well I don't think I've ever
clicked I think I maybe clickbait proof
I'm not bragging I'm just saying I don't
think I've ever clicked on I'll be more
specific an article related to something
I'm reading online I don't cheat you
already looking at the next one yeah
yeah I'm distracted I don't think I ever
I don't think I ever click on I clicked
on this next question like it was a
click hole do you you click on you you
get to the bottom of an article and you
click on another article all the
freaking time effort never why do you
think those exist do you think do you
think it wouldn't be an incredible
business model if there weren't a lot of
people who were susceptible to it I mean
I am so susceptible to that that's why I
love reading Twitter moments because
they're so quick and limited like I just
don't read articles but here's the thing
as I get again I didn't I don't like the
feeling of getting sucked into things so
here's the thing this is why we it's a
burden this is why we work well together
because if we both were like me there
would be a problem and if we were both
like you yeah yeah you know it's like
but if we had to choose
no no it's it there's an in again this
is we talked about this before when
people ask us about the creative process
but like and again this is why I don't
consider myself a procrastinator because
I'm very much an initiator and a starter
it's like I'm the one who wants us to
start on something but you're the one
who wants us to finish something and I
think that I that are tendencies to get
distracting to be like alright listen we
like sometimes I'll be like we
have seven minutes before this thing
starts and I want to start a
conversation about a project that you're
not ready to talk about because you
don't want to talk about it unless we
have two hours to talk about it and I'm
like yeah we've got seven minutes in
seven minutes we may solve the biggest
problem seven minutes worth of it is how
I feel with this with my leg you know
and I'm like we may make the
breakthrough that we've got to make in
this seven minutes mm-hmm and so and but
then sometimes it's like well it's not
worth to get into the seven minutes
because it made us be frustrating so
there's a little bit of a give-and-take
that I think ends up working really well
or you read this next one the envelope
is open jacob asks i don't have a
question so much okay desire to see the
statistics of my life on a spreadsheet
which we just alluded to the statistics
of my life on a spread to pissed off
like words i said the most in least with
an accurate word count as well as how
many breaths I took among other things
was it on a podcast that we talked about
this exact thing or was it just where we
talk I think we did talk a little bit
about records of everything but the
thing specifically I don't think we've
discussed that he makes me think of here
is stuff like words I've said it's
interesting that with all the like
little the lifestyle data that he would
want tracked into statistical form on a
spreadsheet that his first examples are
stupid stuff like what words I've said
the most and now I found myself
interested in that too we started to
make an observation that we both said of
a couple of things a lot on on this show
on GMM 2 and it was right off the bat
and we say right off the bat alone I
noticed it I noticed it on this show and
I think somebody commented right so we
say right off the bat a lot right off
the bat
I've been trying to be more conscious of
it and there was another phrase that
there's quite a few that that we said
you say golly I noticed that golly
it's like Gomer Pyle yeah I think that's
that's one you might want to you might
want to watch yourself back saying that
one why on this show
no I'm GMM like when you react into
something like your go-to phrase for
exasperation is golly I bet you you say
it a thousand times a week I want to see
a golly supercut I've asked I've asked
the editors to cut all of them out so
they never see good no I think they make
it through I do think that this is okay
so i I've been reading it's a long book
and I kind of I work it in this is
another thing I do that is indicative of
my you could call this procrastination I
read between 7 to 10 bucks at a time
I cannot read one book at a time like at
any given time there are that many books
that I am some of the way through and
the majority of them I probably don't
finish so I'm not saying this is a good
thing I'm just giving you the facts of
the way my life works but I'm I'm
working in that sapiens the the the
sequel to sapiens the homo Deus he talks
about basically data ist's data ISM is
sort of the age that we're in right now
in terms of the ultimate thing that
matters to people is that is the data
and that's how we make decisions and so
the person who has the data has the
power so many things can be measured I
mean for us is you know content creators
on YouTube I mean YouTube gives you so
much data about everything about how
many people in what are what types of
people are they and how much of an
individual video do they watch and when
do they stop watching it at what rate do
they drop off and yeah I mean you you've
got your phone recording your number of
steps and you don't even know it well
and the thing is is that you can get to
a place or if you're driving if you get
you get to a place where something isn't
even worth doing if you're not gathering
the data as it's happening you
like that the extreme data is sort of
position is that the any problem can be
solved with it and I mean I think I
think I'm in this boat I think it's
probably the best thing that we've got
to go on right now like so if we're
gonna be arguing about something like
controversial issues like if you get
into something like climate change which
is very dividing politically okay it's
just like and so what people begin to do
is they begin to go to the data right
and what does the data suggest and the
person who has the most data and the
most accurate data can win that argument
and so and I think that that I think it
does apply to and it does help us make a
lot of decisions about things but for me
like when I think about if I were to see
a breakdown of the way that I spent my
time when I'm trying to work on
something I would probably be like a
little bit ashamed of it and be like
that article you read about Danny
Bonaduce that led to the article about
Danny Bonaduce 'he's son that led to the
article about Danny Bonaduce 'he's danny
bonaduce son's prom date who is a meth
addict I don't know I made all that up
all that and I that was chosen Bonaduce
cuz that's a hard word to say that
wasn't fruitful that did not contribute
positively to my life I also don't like
feeding into that whole system that
people are making money off people like
me clicking on things so I think that if
I could see this it's just like when I
came to you and I said we have both been
saying right off the bat a lot
especially me but you've been saying it
too that was data that changed how often
we say right off the bat which
ultimately makes a better podcast right
because it's just like when you're
reading something and you notice that
people say the same phrase of the same
word it feels like this is not this
isn't great writing this isn't a great
book that guy just said coincidentally
twice in that paragraph hack you know
what I mean so
I would love to have this power
I remember the thing that we were
talking about we were talking about the
number of it was something related to
our kids like seeing which of our kids
or what we weren't talking about how
many rolls of toilet paper you go
through I can't remove it is but it was
something from this from this table that
we were talking about about tracking
data but we interacted with it so much
like the gym I go to if you wear your
heartrate monitor they send you a graph
of the whole workout like what you did
and how many calories you burned
supposedly and your heart rate and all
that you know it's all of that all of
this data then it's supposed to I found
myself looking at it and then it
provides some motivation and this is
ultimately why you know people are
really nervous about this understandably
so about having some sort of microchip
implanted inside your body and you know
there's already people doing it right
now
and there's people who have a lot of
hang-ups about it whether it's about
it's a particular way that they see
things religiously as if this has like
the whole mark of the beast' thing
mm-hmm and then there's other people who
are just like very wary of the
government and any time that you can be
tracked or you can be controlled if
you've got some sort of Bionic nature to
you I get all those concerns but the
driving force that is eventually going
to move us into transhumanism like we
talked about with the Zoltan ich we
didn't talk about it with him but Zoltan
ich fun is that his name you know the
guy that we endorsed for president who
continues to be following on Twitter and
I continue to see the stuff that he
talks about the thing that's gonna
ultimately get us there isn't going to
be the convenience of buying and selling
I think it's going to be the fact that
the data gathering and processing that
the people with transhumanist parts are
going to be able to have so when you're
so you're gonna have an advantage over
somebody else when you can do things
like measure your heart rate constantly
and the number of breaths that you took
and what's happening with the food that
you're eating
when you can begin measuring all that
stuff and it begins listening to you and
telling you what you're saying and what
you're not saying and you're gonna be a
little bit more powerful because you're
gonna have access to that data you're
and that's what's gonna altum Utley and
people are gonna the whole privacy thing
is good it's gonna be this like huge
battle over the privacy thing and people
are gonna be super wary about having
anything in them that can be tracked
they're gonna get over it that's what
eventually they're gonna get over it and
it's in everybody it's gonna be
everybody's gonna have it people are
gonna go people are gonna fight about it
though potential potential bloodshed
over it it's gonna get serious but on
the other end of it over the the privacy
debate yeah so would you like to I mean
you're being served up ads based on
conversations you're having with people
I mean the technology is already
listening to everything we're saying
wouldn't you just you know it's wouldn't
you like to have access to the data just
to know how how how you talk how many
times you say certain phrases or I would
yeah it would be kind of cool but I mean
it's kind of like you know it's it's a
very it seems to me a very good thing
for cops to wear body cameras because it
you know it's it's a record that holds
exactly that that holds them accountable
because we hold them to a standard of
excellence in the job that is so
important that we depend on so much and
it has such such a sway over Society
I'll just leave it at that well
especially but it but reason to believe
that people are being taken advantage of
in those did you so if if there's
potential for people to be taken
advantage of and there is potential and
there's plenty of evidence that that
happens all the time then clearly that's
only going to be better for society if
we have access to that information and
what those body cams are recording I
mean I'd like to hear the argument on
the other side as it relates to my
personal privacy but I cause I attend
say well I'm not proud of everything I
sing in do by any means but I you know I
aspire to be the type of person that
like if anybody saw a transcript of what
what I said and did that I would be I'd
be okay with that
because what about a transcript of what
you thought I guess so I mean because
the control you can't you know you can't
control your thoughts you can control
what you do with them but that sounds
really scary it does okay but I am fully
aware of the fact that this whole
transhumanism thing is quickly moved to
a place where your thoughts are being
openly shared right and no this is it's
it's do some really interesting stuff so
I I don't know what book it is what
movie it is but I'm sure it's been done
where they've been begin to police your
thoughts so basically if you have the
thought of committing murder well if the
cops can know that that's what you're
thinking about shouldn't they take
action on it that's the kind of the
argument you can see how easily this
completely gets out of hand right
because freedom of thought freedom if
there's this even freedom of speech is
an example I should be able to say I
should be able to wish death on whoever
I want to and as long as I actually
don't do that physically we've cut in in
in the United States of America for the
most part we have decided that you have
the freedom unless you're talking about
like the President to basically say what
you want to and
but but that is that is also be that's
kind of in question right now people are
beginning to question that but the idea
that your thoughts are suddenly now
transparent to anyone who wants to
access them which i think is ultimately
where this is all going is essentially
changing the way we see humanity from
the hyper individualistic way that we
see people now to more of one organism
and there's a there's a really
interesting writing about this not that
I can remember and point you to because
i'm haven't read enough about it but
basically and it's really scary for us
to think about very scary for us to
think about for all for lots of good
reasons but basically it's the way that
you know like a colony of ants
communicates with each other and
basically they have their thoughts are
super super simple and they don't have
like a product ants don't have a private
life they are part of this organism that
is the colony of ants and they're
communicating and of course with what
they're trying to do is is is is not
nearly as complex what we're trying to
do but them having access to each
other's thoughts through what's
happening with their pheromones and the
way that all that works it's a great
benefit to them there's a lot of people
who believe that we're moving quickly to
a place where we're treating humanity as
an organism and there's some really
weird moral things that start coming up
because then you start people start
justifying things like well if we're
just an organism
well these individuals set it like a
bunch of cells that contribute to a body
well if these cells are not contributing
or these cells are cancerous for
whatever reason let's just get rid of
those cells and now you got individuals
who I'm not so I'm not saying this is
something I'm looking for right this is
not gonna happen in our lifetime it's
not something I'm looking forward to
being ushered in but I think with
technology the way that is progressing
it's an inevitable destination for
Humanity well you scare me too but to
definitely back off I mean even I think
about like it's not my thoughts which is
very disturbing I've got disturbing
thoughts and they don't become speech
for good reason there are exceptions and
I try to learn my lesson but even
stepping back from that saying like a
transcript of what I've said because you
know I don't have anything to hide even
in the transcript form it's like I've
texted enough people to know you can get
in trouble with misinterpretation of
just raw words on a page I mean it just
doesn't so even that seems dangerous
well but what it would if I could know
what if every person could know every
single thing that every other person was
thinking now give it if that was
suddenly if we press a button and that
happened given the way that we built the
society there would be a lot of an
incredible initial shock just like an
amazing shock like if if you if all of a
sudden you're working well everything
that you think and vice versa there
would be this shock right but don't you
think that after the initial explosion
of realization that we could be at a
healthier place as a society if
everybody knew what everybody was
thinking that back together would take
decades ultimately well what that was
the new reality I believe that there are
people like on a spectrum of I'll just
call it purity like purity of mind
purity of motive like I I certainly know
that there are people who are motivated
more by love or greed just to take two
examples okay like I really enjoy
reading about mr. Rogers can't wait for
that movie to come out it's so
interesting to read about this guy who
the way that he talked about him him
himself in interviews was this a level
of unselfish
pure motive of of love that I wish I had
that like I read articles about mr.
Rogers
in order to be inspired to be to make
decisions to become more like someone
who he was naturally but what if you
were able to tap into Rogers his
thoughts so can you found out that it
was all an act
I'm not saying it was I'm not trying to
I'm convinced that it was not an act but
what if it wasn't so no and so why don't
my point is because I'm convinced that
it's not before I take your hypothetical
I'm saying that's what would that's the
first thing that would come out was how
many people were like there would be a
ranking of purity of motives I mean
across politics certainly I mean it
would be something that like would be on
the ballot be like this is the the data
suggests this this purity of of motive
like how you know you'd be able to you'd
have you'd have a another indicator of
how owned a politician was that wasn't
just like the pork barrels or what have
you caught yeah but then it goes to
everybody I think it would be there
would be a ranking of of where everybody
was that on a character but you could
only get that if you had access to the
thoughts is that what you're saying I
think so yes because I think what we
what we asked for a lot of times I think
one of the reasons that the internet has
become a genre of entertainment and
vlogging has become a shanwa of
entertainment that's not going away
anytime soon
is authenticity right we want
authenticity we want transparency and I
realized that that there's this whole
I'm not saying that privacy is not
important all I'm saying is that there's
so many times where you really just wish
you knew what someone's actual motives
were and of course in a society where we
don't have any way to penetrate beyond
just what people say and maybe if we're
really skilled we can kind of interpret
some of their body language or whatever
it's invasive if you're a if you're able
to actually get into somebody's thoughts
against their will obviously it's super
invasive but if it was just a given that
the way that the world worked is that
you could you can know what everyone was
thinking in the same way that you can
know what everyone is doing it's
interesting to think just to think about
what what existence would become because
right now there's it feels like one out
of every hundred people is a sociopath
right you know they'd only have the
ability to to empathize
with people and but they're really good
at seeming normal you don't know the
people who are that way in your life if
you knew how everybody was thinking you
know I guess the question is then what
does that person do what does the person
who's got the thoughts that would cause
them to be guilty in the eyes of other
people do at that point
it sounds like we're kind of trapped
black mirror episode like the one I have
not seen about like the human Yelp
reviews but it would be much more
definitive it wouldn't be people
reviewing their interactions with you
and that's which again would be a big
indicator of character but I mean it's
like people would have reason to lie
well there's a couple of black mary
episodes that explore this right there's
one in one of the first couple of
seasons that explores this essentially a
score that you have based on the way
that you're ranked by other people
that's what the one I was talking to me
and so you but then there's there's a
the other one which is about the
compatible in this season the most
recent season which is about
compatibility with people and it's like
a simulation that's running in it's well
pretty awesome you just spoiled one
because that's the one you and I wash
together oh look we can't say which one
that is because that's a spoiler but
yeah I mean they're without a doubt
every single thing that we're talking
about can be horrific alee nightmarishly
abused and probably will be but also
didn't seem but your point is on the
other side like if you could
fast-forward through the pain of
transition wouldn't we all want to know
I think only the people who have nothing
to hide which doesn't everybody have
something to hide yeah but if but but if
it's in but if it's such a if it's a
smaller percentage of who you are that
you're no one has pure character not
even mr. Rogers but I don't know I think
he may be one of the yeah you know it's
then on the other side of okay we're
going to we're gonna elect this person
because this is their character this is
what their character comprises of
well we know without a doubt that the
way things are done right now is in
terms of how we elect our leaders is not
a good system
you know we know right now that it's
based on this amount of finances you
have it's based on how well you are at
marketing yourself
showmanship it might be based on how
much you can how well you can lie like
we have a lot of things in our system
right now that reward a lot of things
that we don't want in our leaders so I'm
just saying that as crazy as it would be
to get to a place like that if I were to
tell you that you know what I've been to
heaven and I know what heaven is like in
heaven is a place where everyone is
completely transparent and everyone
communicates telepathically with one
another and you are exactly who you are
in all your raw glory and we all exist
in peace in harmony with one another you
might be like oh I can see that it's how
heaven would be and be like well
technology through a lot of ups and
downs is eventually going to get us to a
place where we're communicating
seamlessly with one another as a human
organism but but I think we would I
think I think a perfect knowledge of
everyone's character would would re
stratify society such a way that because
because just but that's already half
that already happens it would be a
different it would really shuffle and I
and I think that the people who aren't
trustworthy or have ulterior motives or
who act upon greed much more than love
you start to have a strata that way and
then you've got you get you've got
greedy people with less money well your
and what are they gonna do but you're
assuming they they're gonna become
dangerous you're assuming that
transparency would lead to a place where
we were reordering our society and the
people at the top would be the ones with
the best motivations I don't necessarily
think the transparency wheelie did that
I think when somebody was screwing you
over you wouldn't know it but that
doesn't that necessarily that wouldn't
necessarily keep somebody from screwing
you over because I think the same things
well I think for politics I mean for
elected officials it would be you know
would right that would be the first
thing that would change I would hope
so then you'd have people with the more
impure your character was the the least
likely that you would be elected to
anything trusted I you know and it would
create I wanted really nasty I want to
believe that you're right but we have
more access to people's personal eyes
and their information and their
background than we ever did and we seem
to as opposed to holding people to a
higher standard we're holding our
politicians to a lower standard than we
ever did you remember back in the day
back in the day being like 10 years ago
when if you found out that a person
running for president had like a maid
working at their house who was an
illegal alien
they were completely out of the race
like that was it he had an undocumented
worker working at his house you know and
that right there was it you were out you
could not run for president that was a
scandal ten years ago
yeah think about the stuff that people
are willing to tolerate now it's crazy
the way things have changed we know so
much more about what people have done
and we just simply not care so then why
do you want to know even more because
you're painting a different trajectory
which is even worse I'm not painting a
trajectory in terms of what I think I'm
just saying that I think that whenever
things start there's an inevitable
direction that technology moves us into
and you just kind of have to know this
is where we're going there's so many
Luddites who just want to keep pushing
back technological advances it's
eventually going to get there it's like
pushing and pushing back on an ocean
that is slowly eroding a coastline you
can't change it you can build a wall you
can build an eddy yeah I mean you can
build like you know whatever they do
whatever those things are called I
should know I'm a civil engineer but I
can't think of it right now but
eventually all that stuff is gonna get
washed away and so I'm not saying you
should just let it all happen you should
do it smartly but you shouldn't deny
that it's actually gonna happen we're
gonna be transhumanist man it's going to
happen unless we destroy ourselves let's
look at this not through the political
lens but through the lens of family for
a second you know the family what we
make fun if you listen listen to the top
of our conversation you know
our dad conversation we find comedy and
you know how selfish we are as dads and
it's in this cathartic to joke about it
because it's our way of saying you know
what I'm I'm we're far from perfect
dad's you know you make the whole
freaking three-point competition about
you at a certain point that's right you
know and it's it's funny because it's
true you know and I aspire to be someone
like who is just so honest like there's
an appeal to podcasting because I think
there's a lot of successful podcasters
who just they're they're not they don't
seem like they're hiding anything I'm
sure they still are but it's very it's
very intoxicating and engrossing to
listen in on a conversation with
somebody who's not doesn't seem to be
holding anything back but if if my
children knew exactly what I thought
about them in a particular moment like I
mean I they could listen to the podcast
I know some of it because I joke about
it and I do joke with them about it and
they wouldn't I don't think they would
be crushed to know that there are plenty
of times when I I'm annoyed to no end by
them and I don't want to be around him I
don't think they would be surprised but
I think it would hurt really bad if they
could experience those thoughts in the
moment you know initial because by the
way they feel the same way about me with
the eyes rolling you know in the the
comments that are made don't you wish I
mean it goes both ways was in it in so
so let's explore that well the last
thing I don't want to do is crush the
heart of my children you would already
problem you would only crush their
hearts because we have been we live in a
society where we've never broken through
that where it right it's crazy like our
entire like biology is based on the fact
that with the only thing that we kind of
have to ourselves is our thoughts you
know like we haven't evolved in a place
where our thoughts other than the way
the ways that our thoughts are expressed
through emotions or with facial
expressions and those things that we've
learned but there's a very important
core which is you know it's in there and
it's protected and it's our own and we
value it probably more than anything and
that's why there's a lot of people who
are listening right now we're just
really uncomfortable with the whole
conversation and I'm gonna comment have
I already commented I don't like when
you guys talk about this kind of stuff
talk about stuff that's lighter hearted
whatever and I completely understand
that and you're not wrong because it's
just an uncomfortable thing to talk
about well and and it would be really
uncomfortable for you to suddenly know
exactly what your kids think about you
and to know that they also know what
what you think about them but what you
feel about your kids or what your kids
feel about you and the reason why is is
what everybody feels about their family
and the reason why I bring it up is
because my love for my kids and their
love for me is not in question so I'm
bringing it up as a thought exercise
because even when you love somebody with
your whole heart there's still there's
still things that if they knew exactly
what you were thinking it would hurt
their feelings there wasn't in a moment
there would be this nuclear bomb that
goes off in everyone's brain at the
moment that they had access to each
other's thoughts and we'd be like I
can't believe that that person thinks
that oh my you that's the kind of thing
that you think about I can't I can't
look at you the same anymore but in that
moment you've also released your
thoughts to someone else and they're
thinking the exact same thing about you
everybody would kind of realize ooh
we're all pretty nasty
we're all pretty good and pretty nasty
and there are some exceptionally good
people and there are some exceptionally
bad people and then there kind of most
of us and I don't I mean I don't know
what the outcome would be it would
probably probably be pretty bad for
those exceptionally bad people
and then they'd all get together that's
what I was getting at in a new strata
and it would the bad people would revel
it's like oh we can now band together I
know how bad you are like we're gonna do
some bad bad stuff we'd send it all to
Australia like they did back in the day
when they sent all the inmates to
Australia so we'll do that yeah let's
run that by the Aussies when we go down
there at the end of July Wow okay this
is this has been quite a conversation
thank you to Morgan and Jacob for asking
these questions that led us down this
rabbit hole which got a little dark made
some of you very uncomfortable I I do
think that within the safety of loving
relationships in an effort to bring some
conclusion to at least part of this
little positive in on a positive I think
so
well aspiration at least I aspire to be
increasingly honest within those loving
trusting relationships because I believe
that it that it it leads to growth and
it leads to understanding it and knowing
like truly loving somebody that you
don't that that you don't fully know is
and what is full what is to fully know
somebody but to get closer to fully
knowing somebody is to is to more fully
love them I think you have to you know
when you love somebody you've got to
love the you got to you got to love the
the Boortz too and if you can get to a
place where you have radical honesty if
we can get to a place as a society where
we have radical honesty then the
inevitable transition into whatever the
next version of humanity is which will
someday definitely include the ability
to read each other's thoughts it won't
be that big of a leap and more the more
the more you have to hide the more
frightened you are of that moment mm-hmm
but that moments gonna come it's not
gonna come in our lifetime if you're
listening to this in the year 2018
you don't have to worry about this well
it might come when you die it might come
for all this when we done you escape the
simulation well or I mean depending on
what you believe we need it right
I would like to commit to be more honest
and I'll get to it eventually get it I
like that
get it I'm an agreement good luck with
that but not really we'll talk at you
next week
thanks for listening and processing this
with us using hashtag ear biscuits oh
and those of you who know the books that
have been written about some of the
stuff that we kind of touched on I'm
sure there's some really good science
fiction about what we've touched on
recommend that to us with hashtag ear
biscuits because I definitely want to
read some of that stuff that better
explains this you know who you are
[Music]